hello and welcome back to game sports
continuing III coverage it is day one
and this morning we had a Nintendo
Direct where we had the lovely Miyamoto
San revealing more from Star Fox zero
with me is Ali rap from Nintendo
treehouse and we also have this lovely
lady off stage demoing the game for us
uh Allie let's talk a little bit about
Star Fox he's back yeah starter box is
Matt my pox McLeod is back um peppy hare
slippy everyone loves slipping hold for
some reason Falco um yeah and they're
back and they're going up against and
Ross yeah so you know just kind of on a
lot of things that you love from the
from the old Star Fox games are back but
it plays completely differently so it's
going to be a completely new experience
for people who've grown up with it and
of course for people who maybe didn't
grow up with it yeah like I mean I'm
gonna put my cards on the table here I
did not have a nintendo 64 so string me
up in the later but this morning before
the hordes descended on the los angeles
conventions and i did get a chance to
play a Star Fox zero on the wii u so
let's talk a little bit about how the
game handles because yeah it is it is
gamepad heavy yep um and you have to
kind of get to grips with that and
they're all kind of it clicks so talk
about what the gamepad brings through
yeah yeah so we're actually going
through the training mission right now
I'm Sarah's playing for us and what the
training mission is showing us is that
you think of it like your um your ship
your our wing controls independently
from your guns okay and so what you do
is you have the gamepad gyro as your gun
aiming so if you're familiar with
splatoon you know kind of lat been
aiming mechanic and and then you control
the ship that are weighing with the
sticks and so what you need to do is you
need to be looking at the gamepad to aim
the guns yeah um and then you need to be
looking at the TV to steer the ship for
the most part because the TV is going to
give you this kind of like
big view of what's going on around the
ship whereas the gamepad view is going
to give you more of that like very
detailed okay I'm hitting that enemy i'm
hitting that obstacle so it's this
really unique use of kind of that dual
screen play yeah um to make it feel like
you're actually in the cockpit of the
arwing right because that's what the
game had to be was supposed to be and
the cockpit view and so you know of
course you've got the sinks you've got
the gyro you've got the dual screen and
then of course you've got like the
button the button moves like you've got
your u-turns and you're you're a barrel
rolls of course and of course he would
not be a softbox game win about the
barrel roll yeah the barrel roll does
return so right now you know the game is
just teaching us the basics getting us
used to controlling the guns with a gyro
flying around things target view so what
you can do is you can target onto an
object whether it's your objective or
like an enemy and the you'll be able to
then kind of fly around in this
cinematic view and I don't think sarah
can hear us or I'll she would do it for
us but um so let's talk a little bit
about I mean how easy it is to get to
grips with two ones because I found that
like because I I was stupid okay I went
straight you're not stupid in the main
mission cuz I thought I played a lot of
games oh the turns out I could couldn't
beat the boss a lovely lady on the
Nintendo stanphill sorry if it makes you
feel any better I died in the coronary
Abbas to UM so it's just it's kind of
crazy how well how quickly things can go
from being steady just a nice measured
pace yeah going through hoops yep into
oh my god everyone's attacking me help
me yeah yeah and so you know what we
want to do is we want to get give people
that that feel for how it feels to
control in an open space or on Rails
before they jump into something like
that you know and my boss or something
more tricky like um say maybe area 3
which is also in the e3 demo um but yeah
it's one of those things where you know
listening to how it controls like man I
don't know if I can do that that sounds
tricky and that's like a lot of things
to keep track of um and you know it's
gonna take you a little bit but once you
get it you like you said it's just like
I get it right it clicks you get it it
it it is intuitive in a lot of ways like
when it was presented to me it was like
you're gonna have the hardest time with
this it's so hard you're never going to
get it nobody's ever going to get it
we're everyone is bad at video games
ever and so I went into it thinking that
you know it was going to be really
tricky but when I picked it up I thought
hey this is actually pretty intuitive I
can once i understand that I need to
look at both screens yep and that pic of
the idea that the guns and the ship are
controlled separately then it kind of
clicked right legs I mean that's how it
would be right right i mean right like
you don't in real life you know you
don't sear your plane where you want to
shoot no you shoot while you're steering
the plane in a different direction and
so yeah I mean early in the the Nintendo
usual event mr. Miyamoto was talking
about how we wanted to kind of simulate
what it feels like to actually fly the
plane and that's part of it right my
favorite things from that was that he
the idea from Star Fox not only came
from the famous shrine that he lived by
isn't that he let you watch Thunderbirds
of this you know weirdest mishmash
meetings I hoping to come together to
create something really great yeah yeah
yeah it was a it's a great story and see
how we're in wording corneria now which
old Star Fox fans might recognize and
there are some familiar things about
Star Fox zero which will kind of bring
you back I'm of course some of a lot of
characters return um someone kind of the
areas but it really is especially with
the way that you move around this space
and think about the way that you're
controlling the arwing like it's it's
such a different experience it's a
different way to experience starbucks in
a lot of big ways so it's gonna be
awesome oh oh we also have the Walker oh
wow I wonder yeah let's kind of see what
yet sir yeah show us one of the big
things yeah this was a gameplay mechanic
that was cut from the side
they never surfaced stuff over there
there was some yeah I think they were
talking about that the digital event
right talking about how some of those
elements like a walker you know our kind
of resurfacing they wanted to share
those things with uh with folks so let's
see if Sarah can pick up the Walker
she's great she's really into she's
brilliant Angie I think she's got it uh
oh there we go it's kind of nice like we
see this in games like obviously mario
kart 8 yes I transformation sonic all
stars race transformed but this kind of
gives it like it completely different
feel because it obviously not on a track
you're free to run around yeah yeah take
the level at the pace that you want yeah
yeah the Walker is really good for I
actually like it because it is like it's
not quite as fast as the arwing and it a
little bit more of a disabled experience
yes because you're not super worried
about like controlling your height and
so if you need to like really focus on
taking down enemies who are bugging you
up in the air especially like an all
range mode when you're flying all around
I think it's super great for that and of
course it's also good for exploring like
there will be stages later where you
like you go through tunnels and you
don't want to do that in an airplane so
you can go into the Walker
transformation but a nice thing you can
do is that if you're in Waka mode you
can hover so if you have you do need to
kind of be able to yeah you need to get
up in the equity oh you just kind of
pulled it from yeah yeah yeah there's
some there's a walker can do that on the
landmaster returns and has a sort of
like that and where you can kind of
hover above the ground there's the gyro
wing so there's a few transformations
that you can go in do in the game to
kind of now you know change it up
depending on what kind of stage you're
going into whether it's one more cramped
stage or kind of a more stealthy stage
so this will go a little bit what what
Star Fox zero is so mr. Miyamoto said
you know when we're pulling things from
old games but this isn't a sequel yep
this is kind of a fresh take not
necessarily a reboot right right yeah so
I like to think of it as kind of like a
reimagining so if you're familiar with
the Star Fox series and you're a fan
you're gonna see a lot of things you're
like oh yeah that gives me feels you
know I missed that um
like Dwight corneria like the characters
like in the ring things like that but it
it it's not the same yeah and like for
example the boss and then Akron area is
completely different but that's not the
only thing you know like i like to think
about how even if it was a completely
same game which it's not yeah to any of
them um the way that you control the
arwing is just like so fundamentally
different than the way that you'd
control they are weighing in in any of
the previous games okay to be an
experience it feels like it's it's
brought it into the modern age and that
so it's still gonna hit on all of those
nostalgia beats for people who played
the original game on the n64 on the says
whatever and but it's also accessible
enough for new gamers because obviously
nintendo are they brought motion gaming
yep to the masses yes they continue to
do so with the wii u and being able to
use the gyro yeah sort of this new
intuitive way yeah yeah yeah i think i
like i love the way that the gyro works
and i love that it works um i'm the same
way with splatoon like you can use the
six in splatoon but i actually prefer
the gyro like a quicker it's more
accurate um and this the same goes for
the way that it controls with Star Fox
zero like I love having my our weight
control with the six and then the aiming
be able to have that like quicker turn
with the gyro um it's just and it's like
if you think about like if it were a
starbucks game from the old days and you
brought it to just like a normal control
or whatever like you've got like your
four buttons or something it's like I've
get those kind of flat right but now
you've got so many new exciting things
to learn that I'm just like I'm really
excited to pick this up I even really
like gotten into a Starbucks game since
a star fox 64 I guess you could count
star fox adventure yeah but not quite
one of a different experience um and so
I'm super excited to get into 0 & 2 just
like kind of relearn what I thought I
knew yeah about so let's talk a little
bit about the story so Fox McCloud and
all his friends return
what is the kind of is this kind of
gonna be running on the same themes is
there's a story we've seen before is it
gonna take us in a kind of new
unexplored oh right right so all we know
now is that Andros is involved and and
Ross is still naughty naughty pants and
it's up to star foxes gang yeah good
gang to take down and Ross but that's
really all we're all right none anything
you let on to ya here is the giant boss
fight that I met yeah yeah um it's the
weaponized flying for us of course it is
ridiculous um so I mean let's take a
look at how Sarah's gonna yeah yeah
Elvis yeah and you can actually take
this boss town in a couple different
ways yeah um you can shoot down like all
the top guns and make it fall so I was I
was trying to take out each laser yeah
yeah or what she did is she shot down
one and then it toppled one of the sides
and what she can then do the T if she's
gonna do it um is there's like a little
hole that she can go ahead with the
Walker yep yeah and what she can then do
is let see if she can make it oh yes
nice this is a great great example of it
just the transformation and how you can
yeah yeah thanks yeah yeah and this is
totally this way is totally optional I
didn't know about it until somebody at
work was like did you know you see what
um so you can go in and take out and
take down the core we're just simply
we've kind of took we've said how great
the gyroscope is can you play it on just
the the game of the pro controller TBD
TBD he's is it Nintendo yeah yeah I
strongly recommend really spending some
time with the gyro because it is like it
is a really really cool way to play the
game it was the thing that the wood
platoon someone had a pro controller and
just touched and uncheck to it right oh
I don't know I always play the game pad
yeah I mean whatever you guys whatever
you crazy folks do yeah it's like it
here you gonna MacGyver I'll wash it
down yeah uh which is organized I've not
seen this before so well I'd like the
first time to you yeah it took me a
while oh and a nice salute do you have
general pepper I also like to think of
um I think it was maybe a star fox 64
when the voices were like my aunt feber
you know like it was like the shaky
voice yeah it's my favorite part I don't
think they do that in this one but Ali
thank you so much yeah you so much to
start demoing Star Fox zero for us when
is it out I believe it's this any later
this to you later this year I believe
believe check mckenna com the later this
year holiday oh honey 15 buddy thank you
so much make sure you stay tuned here to
gamespot because we have tons more
amazing coverage from e3 2015 don't go
anywhere